[Musica]
no
oggi più che mai parlare i disastri è
fondamentale secondo le nazioni unite
tra il 2000 e 2011 sono stati circa 2.7
miliardi le persone coinvolte in
disastri in tutto il mondo
e a causa dei cambiamenti climatici
disastri naturali negli ultimi dieci
anni sono più che raddoppiati e disastri
naturali porta una scarsità di risorse a
conflitti sociali migrazioni guerre la
mia esperienza di coordinatore di
protezione civile ha insegnato e
cambiando la percezione del rischio
molte vite possono essere salvate e
molti disastri possono essere evitati mi
pongo una domanda avete più paura di
subire un attacco terroristico oppure di
prendere la vostra auto
quanti di voi hanno più paura di subire
un attacco terroristico
e quanto invece di prendere la propria
auto
ok perfetto
beh per quanto la maggioranza delle
persone ovviamente più spaventata dal
subire un attacco terroristico
le probabilità di morire in un incidente
stradale sono molto più alte quindi mi
raccomando quando tornate a casa stasera
e vi porta un altro esempio in che modo
una cattiva percezione della realtà e
quindi del rischio o compromettere le
nostre azioni
prendiamo quello che è successo ad
esempio l'anno scorso a torino c'erano
alcuni suoni colpi persone che
scappavano e in pochi minuti ci sono
stati un morto e oltre 1.500 feriti
semplicemente verona cattiva percezione
di quello che stava succedendo
il timore degli attentati era veramente
molto forte in quel periodo e quindi le
persone hanno interpretato in modo
sbagliato quello che stava accadendo
ma come mai c'è una percezione del
rischio così differente dalla realtà
beh alcuni studi avevano evidenziato che
c'è ovviamente un netto divario di
conoscenza fra i dati che avevano gli
esperti quelli della popolazione infatti
si è provato a cercare di dare accesso a
queste informazioni anche alla
popolazione normale eppure la percezione
del rischio continuava a non coincidere
e infatti voi è stato visto che non
dipende semplicemente da fattori
razionali dai dati ma la percezione del
rischio dipende molto da fattorino
razionale automatici e quali sono quindi
questi fattori che influenzano la nostra
percezione del rischio io vi parlerò di
tre fattori il primo è quello della
familiarità ad esempio gli abitanti ai
campi flegrei ormai vivono il bradisismo
con una forma quasi normale perché è un
fenomeno ricorrente e quindi loro lo
percepiscono come molto meno pericoloso
rispetto a chi magari balli e sente
qualche scossa perché ovviamente non è
abituato e le persone che vivono
abitualmente situazioni di rischio
percepiscono i pericoli in modo molto
differente perché lo mescolano quasi con
la normalità
un secondo fattore è quello del
controllo perché noi ci sopravvaluti a
me lo facciamo sempre e sempre più
rischioso prendere l'auto che l'aereo
però se siamo noi in controllo
dell'autoveicolo della vettura pensiamo
che riusciremo sicuramente a non fare
incidenti e forse la mente umana pensa
addirittura che se fossimo noi la guida
dell'aereo potremmo guidarlo meglio dei
professionisti perché noi
pensiamo di essere bravissimi e quindi a
tenere sotto controllo alla realtà
ovviamente non è così
il terzo la volontarietà quando c'è ad
esempio un allerta meteo chi sceglie di
uscire di casa chi sceglie di non
sentire di non stare a sentire appunto
dall'allerta meteo della protezione
civile percepisce dischi in modo molto
inferiori a chi magari vede l'allerta e
si barrica in casa ora essere a
conoscenza di questi tre fattori
ovviamente riesce a darci una mano per
comprendere il collegamento tra
percezione e comportamenti e sicuramente
il rischio e la riduzione dei rischi da
disastri sicuramente influenzato da
fattori antropici sociali ma soprattutto
dalle scelte che prendiamo chiedere al
proprio comune di conoscere il piano di
protezione civile oppure esigerà una
formazione pratica può fare la
differenza sapere cosa fare in caso di
un temporale può decisamente fare la
differenza spesso appunto mi trovo ad
andare nelle scuole i ragazzi sono
sempre veramente molto molto interessati
a questa tematica e spesso fanno delle
domande potrebbero anche sembrare quasi
banali ma che se non le fanno se i
ragazzi non si pongono certi problemi
quando si trovano poi in una reale
emergenza non sanno cosa fare una
domanda che mi si pone molto spesso
riguarda un'informazione che arriva
parzialmente ovvero durante una scossa
di terremoto ci dicono di non prendere
l'ascensore e di non utilizzare le scale
quindi se mi trovo al quinto piano che
faccio mi butto giù ovviamente no quindi
la risposte subito no poi la seconda
risposta è sicuramente gli ascensori non
vanno presi per quanto riguarda invece
le scale non vanno utilizzate durante la
scossa però subito dopo con attenzione
era dentro muro si possono utilizzare e
parlando di scuole
l'istat ha rilevato che sono tra gli
edifici in italia più a rischio cioè la
maggioranza delle scuole non è a norma
di sicurezza
ora ovviamente siamo tutti a favore di
maggiori investimenti infrastrutturali
ma basterebbe anche qualcosa di molto
più quasi banale per ridurre molto il
rischio anche semplicemente diminuire il
numero di studenti per classe ha quindi
ci renderebbe ovviamente le procedure di
evacuazione molto più rapida e quindi il
rischio diminuirebbe sensibilmente ma
zoomiamo ulteriormente sul nostro
territorio noi adesso siamo in campania
e la campania è nota nel mondo per la
sua storia la bellezza del territorio il
cibo e ovviamente tutelare queste
risorse è interesse di tutti
eppure una chiesa che crolla oppure un
paesaggio deturpato da una frana o
ancora cibo avvelenato dall'inquinamento
sono tutte cose sono tutte cose che
abbiamo già visto e che ovviamente
compromettono il nostro territorio la
nostra identità la nostra essenza e
quindi tutti noi dobbiamo fare qualcosa
per preservare queste risorse
cosa possiamo fare beh sicuramente
informazione educazione partecipazione
sono tutte cose che ci aiutano ad avere
gli strumenti per comprendere meglio il
rischio e quindi a sapere come
comportarsi in caso di emergenza perché
noi siamo tutti parte del sistema di
protezione civile
questo cosa significa che noi tutti
dobbiamo cercare di creare comunitari
seeley enti comunitari silenti che
quindi riescono ad adattarsi a resistere
meglio al cambiamento per uno sviluppo
sostenibile che tenga conto
dell'ambiente in cui ci troviamo lo
sviluppo sostenibile la definizione
internazionalmente riconosciuta è quella
di uno sviluppo che tenga conto dei
bisogni del presente senza però
compromettere quello delle generazioni
future e tutti noi insieme possiamo
contribuire a creare un futuro con
minori rischi perché appunto siamo tutti
parte del sistema di protezione civile
grazie
[Musica]